>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Eric Eldritch: Good
afternoon everyone.
>> Good afternoon.
>> Eric Eldritch: I'm
really glad that you're here
at the Library of Congress.
We hope that you've been able
to make new friends and to meet
with your colleagues from
across the Metro area.
And we're glad to introduce you
to the Library of Congress itself.
Our program today is full of --
of information that will help you
learn how to find information,
and I'll let the speakers do that.
And to give a welcome on behalf of
the -- of the Library of Congress,
I'd like to introduce Dr.
Colleen -- Dr. Colleen Shogun,
who is the Deputy Director of
National and International Outreach.
Would you welcome Dr.
Colleen Shogun?
[ Applause ]
>> Colleen Shogun: Hi everyone.
Good afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
It's great to see you
all here today.
Once again, my name's
Colleen Shogun.
I'm the Deputy Director of National
and International Outreach
here at the library.
And as you might know,
we have a new --
a fairly new librarian
of Congress here at LOC.
Her name is Dr. Carla Hayden.
And she asked me to
welcome you here today.
She regrets that she
can't be here herself.
She's super busy.
She's, you know, in huge
demand all across the city,
all across the United States
and all across the world.
But she definitely is a very
big fan of this program.
So since 1999, the library has
hosted over 230 HACU interns.
And we're very proud to
participate in this program,
which brings new ideas, new minds,
new talents to the
Library of Congress.
And we're also honored to have
received the HACU President's Award
for serving as a leader of --
of advocating for diversity
in the federal workforce.
I understand that you've all had a
brief tour already of the library.
And as probably your docents,
your tour guides have told you,
this beautiful building
that we're in today,
the Jefferson Building
is really a testimony
to a particular moment in time.
The particular moment in time
when the United States was
becoming a world power at the turn
of the century from the 19th
century into the 20th century.
So the building stands
really for the idea
that the United States would
become a world leader as far
as knowledge is concerned and
as far as learning is concerned
and also educational
access for everyone.
The library has adopted the
ideals of Thomas Jefferson.
We know Thomas Jefferson was the
founder in some ways of the Library
of Congress because he provided us
with the very first books to serve
as the Library of Congress.
He believed that free, unhampered
pursuit of truth by an informed
and involved citizen --
citizenry was necessary --
was necessary criteria
for democracy.
It didn't mean that that was a
nice thing to have a democracy,
but it was something that
had to exist for democracy
to function and to flourish.
And there was a time when most
libraries strictly guarded their
doors to knowledge, so libraries
weren't always necessarily open
or free to everyone.
But this institution was
always dedicated to the idea
of universal access
and equal opportunity
and we still are obviously
to this day.
Everyone is welcome to
the Library of Congress.
And I feel very comfortable saying
that because our new librarian
really espouses that --
that principle and talks
about it on a daily basis.
And what she means by that is the
youngest people, and she calls them
"scholars in training," people that
are not even, can't even read yet,
kids that can't even read yet,
welcome to the Library of Congress.
We have a Young Readers
center just one floor down,
and she enjoys going there,
reading stories to them,
reading books to them, trying to
get kids engaged in the notion
of reading and of learning, all the
way up to our high school students
who we encourage to use the Library
of Congress; to our college students
and then our most senior scholars
who come here to the library
to write books and
important research articles.
So the library really belongs
to everyone from the whole range
of early learners all the way to our
-- our most senior intellectuals,
and she really means that sincerely.
The Library of Congress is --
I'm not sure if you know this,
but it is the largest
repository of human knowledge
in the world, which is pretty cool.
I mean it is.
It is the place that has the
most amount in one location
of information and
knowledge in the entire world.
And that's pretty special.
We have 3,000 people.
I'll tell you a little
bit about the numbers.
So what does that mean?
3,000 people work here at the --
about 3,000 people work here
at the Library of Congress
where the main research arm
of the United States Congress,
so we take that mission
very, very seriously.
Before I came to work in outreach
here at the Library of Congress,
I worked at the Congressional
Research Service for many years,
which is a division of the
Library of Congress that works
to serve members of congress
and staff, providing them
with nonpartisan information and
analysis about public policy issues
that are being debated today.
We're also surrounded by 36 million
catalogue books here at the Library
of Congress, print materials
and 460 foreign languages,
69 million manuscripts, the
largest rare book collection in all
of North American and the
world's largest collection
of legal materials,
films, maps, comic books,
sheet music and sound recordings.
So, it's not -- The Library
of Congress is not just books.
Yes, books are a very,
very important part
of our 160 million
object collections,
so that's the foundation
of our collection.
But the library also -- Library
of Congress also recognizes
that you can learn from
a lot of different types
of materials and not just books.
So the library collects
widely, hence the notion
that the library is
the largest repository
of human knowledge in the world.
So the amount of information
is when you think
about it is pretty mind
boggling, 160 million objects,
160 million items that you can learn
from at the Library of Congress.
But then you might say, well,
"Why is that so important today?"
You know, why is it so important
to have physical collections
of -- of these items?
Because, you know,
this phone, right,
in my pocket can put easily 160
million pieces of information
at my fingertips, and I can
walk around with it, you know,
all day here at the library.
It can walk around with it at home.
You can use it for all kinds
of purposes, just curiosity
or actual learning,
scholarship research.
It can be used today.
You can google any question that
you don't know the answer to.
If you're at my house,
you ask Alexa.
That's what I like to
do because I'm lazy.
So now I talk to, you know,
almost like a virtual robot
to answer questions for me.
But the question is,
so you have access.
All this information
is at your fingertips.
There's not a question of the
fact that we don't have access
to information today, and you
don't have to necessarily come
to a library to -- to read a book
or to read a magazine article
or to read a newspaper article.
But the question is,
can you distinguish
between reliable sources?
How do you know what is
actually factually correct?
Do you know the right
questions to ask
to get the answers that you need?
And that works for anything.
That works if you're
using your phone.
That works if you're using
something like Alexa.
My husband is very bad at
asking Alexa questions.
He asks her questions in the wrong
way and he never gets good answers.
So, I mean, just using a
simple device like that,
if you don't know how to use
it, then there may be a lot
of information inside that
device, but you can't gain access
to the information that you need.
And that's really where
libraries play a major role.
The vast amount of information
that has now been made
available has made libraries
and librarians even more important.
Some people would argue it's
made libraries less important
because we're all walking
around with virtual libraries
in our pockets or in our backpacks.
But that's not really true.
Simply, access to more
information doesn't mean
that we don't need experts like
we provide here at the Library
of Congress or any library,
right, the public libraries,
research libraries that
we don't require experts
to help us find the right
answers and the right sources.
As Dr. Hayden likes to say,
"Librarians are the
original search engines."
Library staff makes
it easier for you
to access the correct
information so that you know
when you ask those questions that
you're getting the most reliable
and authoritative answers.
This is not a place that is
thriving on the notion of fake news.
This is not a fake news place.
This is a place that is --
is premised upon the idea of giving
you the best possible information
and giving you the widest
range information --
of information to answer the
questions that you might ask.
So I hope you enjoy today's
lecture on the role of libraries
and the leadership that libraries
play in the quest for knowledge.
As students, I urge you to
return here to the Library
of Congress some day and
conduct your own research,
whether it's research for a course
that you're taking or research
for a paper that you're
writing or something just
that you're personally
curious about.
It doesn't always have to be about
something academic and intellectual.
And I know that's probably
your focus now
because that's what your --
your -- your phase in life,
but it doesn't have to be that when
you come to the Library of Congress
or you come to any, you know,
even your local library.
You can just want to ask a
curious question about a hobby,
about your genealogy, about
historical backgrounds,
about something about your family
or something about your community.
And here at the Library of
Congress, we're here to serve
that entire range of -- of requests
or information that you might need.
Knowing how to access and knowing
how to ask the right questions
to gain accurate information
really is a skill
that will help you no matter
what career you decide
to go, you decide to pursue.
It doesn't really matter, but I
will guarantee you that if you're
in a job, it doesn't matter
what job that you're in --
well most jobs these days,
but getting the answer
correct is the most -- is --
is the most important aspect.
You can do it quickly.
You might be able to write it in a
-- in a very clear, succinct way,
but the bottom line is you have to
get -- the answer has to be correct.
It has to be authoritative.
It needs to be supported
by reliable resources.
And gaining that resource
and learning those --
and learning that skill is something
that you can really take advantage
of here at the Library of
Congress or any library.
So I'm going to turn the
program over to Jonathan.
I think he's going to give us some
announcements about the program.
But once again, welcome
to the Library of Congress
and I hope you enjoy your day and
your internship and the program.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Jonathan Santeliz: Thank
you very much Dr. Shogan.
This is really amazing to be here.
First of all, my name
is Jonathan Santeliz
and I'm the Executive Director
of the HACU National
Internship Program.
We're really happy and we're
really fortunate to be here.
2017 is our 25th year that our
program has been in existence.
And over the course
of those 25 years,
a lot has -- a lot has happened.
We started with just one
agency and 24 interns.
And now we have partnerships with
about 20 or different agencies all
across the federal government.
And we're very fortunate to count
on the Library of Congress as one
of those agencies that has
been a consistent supporter
of the internship program.
I had some remarks that I want to
make, but I also want to acknowledge
to folks that have made
this program possible.
And so first and foremost, the
two individuals that were key
in making this possible, Miss
Hazel Cerron [Assumed Spelling].
If you could please stand so we
could acknowledge you and your work.
[ Applause ]
Alright, Hazel.
And then also from our
internship program,
Miss Francesca Rebar
[Assumed Spelling].
She's back there.
[ Applause ]
Alright.
With these two individuals
worked alongside with Library
of Congress staff to make this event
possible, so please later on today,
please thank them for the
great work that they've done.
I also want to acknowledge the
Library of Congress interns
that we currently have here.
And so if you -- When
I say your name,
if you could please
stand: Mr. Vincent Acuna.
[ Applause ]
Hazel Osegal [Assumed Spelling]
Jocelyn, Miss Jocelyn Gutierrez.
[ Applause ]
Miss Ana Munishkina
[Assumed Spelling].
Did I say that right?
Alright, close, you know.
[ Applause ]
And Miss Wendy Velasquez-Eubanks.
Please. Oh, there you are.
[ Applause ]
Also want to recognize that we
have a few HACU alumni in the crowd
that were interns a few years
back, not too long ago, right.
And they're also here.
And interns I -- I encourage
you to reach out to them,
talk to them so you
can hear their stories.
So first of all, Miss Leah Kerwin --
[ Applause ]
Miss Ella Melissa Gonzalez, yeah.
And Mr. Ricardo Graciafierdo
[Assumed Spelling].
Where are you?
Not here. He stepped out.
Alright, he's -- he's
-- he's back to work.
Alright. I'm going to close
with just a few things.
I've always encouraged the interns
to as you're doing your internship
to capitalize on this opportunity,
to take advantage of the resources.
And you've gotten a lot of
information from Dr. Shogan
about all the amazing
resources that are here.
I want you think of the Library
of Congress as your library, okay,
as the resource that
you can tap into,
as well as within your agencies.
This is the agency.
This is your US Department
of Agriculture,
US Department of Health
and Human Services.
So definitely, as you're here,
don't be shy about taking
in really the beauty of this
building and asking questions
about all the amazing opportunities
and resources that are here.
With that, that is
all I have to say.
Thank you very much for coming here.
And go ahead and introduce
our next speaker,
Mr. George Coulbourne who's
the Chief of the National
and International Outreach Office.
[ Applause ]
>> George Coulbourne: Now
that Jonathan's taken half
of my presentation,
mine will be very short.
Really, I look out at
the audience and I'm --
I'm just really very happy that all
of you could join us here today.
This is a sentinel
event for this program.
I remember back in
early 2000 I think
that there was another new
service unit called the Office
of Strategic Initiatives.
And the head of that service unit,
Laura Campbell who has since retired
and gone on to even bigger
things was very much an advocate
for this type of program, for
giving young men and women a chance
to immerse themselves
in our nation's culture,
all the same time promoting
diversity within the workforce.
The library has always
had a history, most --
especially most recently
for promoting diversity.
It's like any other
government institution.
It waxes and wanes.
But I tell you there are people here
that I can say are truly committed
to promoting diversity
in the workplace.
But today is a celebration of
-- I always get this mixed up.
Is it HACU or HNIP?
So, we'll say today to celebrate
HNIP's program here at the library.
And I would be remiss
not to say that I want
to thank Eric Eldritch
and Julie Lee.
Julie, the two of you stand
up, because they are Hazel's --
[ Applause ]
-- They are Hazel's mentor.
Hazel's has been a real
addition to this team.
We're a relatively
small team, and --
and I think they've worked
extremely well on program --
this program, as well as major
national and international programs
that come out of our office.
So I thank you all.
Really, I want you to know that
this program is truly a critical
component and shows the library's
commitment to promote in a diverse
as I said workforce, to
support the inclusiveness --
the culture of inclusiveness
here at the library.
I know over the years,
it's been some changes
in the way we do things both
from a senior administration
and at the service unit level.
But this has always held
the same, and with the --
with the event of IFP, which is
the Intern and Fellowship Program,
which is part of the National and
International Outreach Service Unit,
we are committed to
really broadening our reach
for internships, fellowships
and residencies in our country.
As I said, Jonathan's already
thanked the Spring HACU interns here
at the library.
I want to thank you.
We met not too long ago.
I was joking with Yoselin
and told her I was going
to call her up to say a few words.
But they've been a great group.
They have made some
major contributions.
And I especially want to take this
time to thank Jonathan and Noel.
They've been wonderful partners.
We've sparred over the
years, but that's --
that's what make it a
good relationship as --
that we do some give and take.
But they have really brought some
great talent here to the library.
Now, for this event,
we're very fortunate
to have an exceptional
leader and librarian.
The Director of Diversity
and Leadership Programs
at the Association of Research
Libraries or the ARL, Mark Puente,
who will challenge you to think
creatively about your future.
At the Association of Research
Libraries, Mark directs all aspects
of this association's
diversity recruitment
and leadership development programs
and serves as the ARL staff liaison
to the ARL Committee on
diversity and leadership.
Now, Mark's research interest
from what we understand
and we hope we have this right
Mark are centered on diversity
and leadership, particularly
in the context
of academic research libraries
and fine arts librarianship.
Mark has been actively involved
with diversity and leadership issues
since the beginning
of his library career.
Mark at one time was also an intern.
He's also a graduate of
the Minnesota Institute
for early career librarians and the
Harvard ACRL Leadership Institute.
In his responsibilities for the
ARL career resources, he designs
and directs the Annual
ARL Leadership Symposium
and leads the planning of the
Bi-Annual National Diversity
and Libraries Conference.
Mark has presented at regional
and national conferences on topics
such as networking, minority
recruitment strategies, diversity,
inclusion in the workplace
and residency programs
and academic libraries.
So it is with great pleasure
that I introduce Mark Puente.
And please join him and welcome
him to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Puente: Thank you
very much for that welcome.
I'm really delighted to be here.
As I was listening to the remark --
I'm going to time myself
to help dictate how fast --
how quickly or how
slowly I can talk.
So -- No, I'm really
delighted to be here.
And as I was listening to some of
the opening programs, I was thinking
about my own experiences not only
as a librarian information
science professional,
but I also had a previous
career as a music educator.
And in my experiences, it was really
the relationships that I built
through the course
of those two careers.
But especially I can tell you a
little bit about my educational path
to librarianship and some
cohorts that were built
as I pursued my Master of
Library and Information Science,
and also I was a spectrum scholar,
which is a large scholarship program
that is funded and sponsored by
the American Library Association.
And some of those relationships
that I built those
programs are really ones
that endure some 16/17 years later.
And I know that you are
-- have the potential
to build some lifelong relationships
that can really help
bolster and help guide you.
You'll be developing peer
mentors through this experience.
So, I really invite you to fully --
really think about taking advantage
of the relationships that
you're building here.
I mean the money was
always really great.
The scholarship money
was great, you know,
less student loan debt,
all that sort of thing.
The practical experience
that I had in some of my --
in my fellowship experience
was really wonderful.
But when I think about my, what
maybe has been most impactful,
I really think about
those relationships.
So please do that.
I'm going to talk just
a little bit today.
It's always in the context -- all
in the context of librarianship
of course, because
that's the current --
that's the world in which I --
through which I navigate right now.
But I'm going to tell
you a little --
start off just by telling
you a little bit about myself
because I hope it's a
little bit relevant.
I was born in -- in
San Antonio, Texas.
This is my beautiful hometown.
I love it.
I miss it.
I go back there.
I still have a home there.
I go back very, very frequently.
I grew up in a pretty modest,
I would say a working class
neighborhood in San Antonio.
This is an intentional for those
of you who may be old enough
to remember my intentional homage
to the Ricky Ricardo/Lucy
and Ricky Ricardo Show.
But if you can see the heart there.
But my father was a brick
mason growing up in San Antonio
for the better part of 60 years.
My mother was at the time that
my parents met in the 50s,
she was a credit clerk in a local --
in a downtown retailer
in downtown San Antonio.
And they met.
They lived -- grew up in
the same neighborhood.
My father was great, a good
singer and that sort of thing.
I should've given you -- I'm sorry,
the -- the trigger alert to this.
Because this slide represents
really I guess the change.
This is very much a part of the
reality that my parents grew up.
The parents -- the San Antonio that
my parents grew up in was very,
very segregated, very divided, and
not only around racial/ethnic lines
as is represented here
in this slide,
but across many, many other lines.
So it was -- it was difficult.
And my parents pretty much I would
say really encouraged my brothers
and I to assimilate, right,
to become more like the --
the majority culture, right, the --
the dominate cultures that
were in San Antonio at the time
because that's what
they saw would be --
That's what they thought would
be our pathway to success.
Hopefully some of that -- a lot
of that maybe is changing now,
as I think about people
that I am trying to shepherd
through in my capacity at
ARL into higher education
into graduate education and
into careers in librarianship.
Now, the San Antonio --
I'm old enough -- I'm --
I'm one of those cusp-ers
[phonetic].
I was a baby boomer, but
just on the cusp a bit.
But this San Antonio that my parents
grew up in like I said was very,
very divided within once
less than probably --
It was probably five square blocks.
There was the church for
the Latinics community,
the Hispanics and Latinos.
There was the church for those
of German and Czech descent
and there was another church for
the African-Americans or the black
or the -- the black congregations.
So it was very, very divided.
And about the late 60's,
that started to kind
of break down a -- a little bit.
And the San Antonio that I grew
up in, especially into my teens,
especially into my 20's and 30's
was really very, very integrated
with the majority cultures
really embracing the --
the flavors and the smells and the
sounds of the Latinics culture,
right, our food -- If you've
ever been to San Antonio --
Has anybody been to San Antonio?
I hope some of you have.
Who -- who are -- Anybody
from San Antonio?
Yeah. No, no?
Okay. I miss breakfast tacos
more than anything I think.
So anyway, but, you
know, home of the --
the Alamo, our world
famous Riverwalk and lots
of -- lots of great food.
Please come visit.
When I was a kid, backtracking
just a few years later,
this was really my first experience
with the library and that was
with the San Antonio Public Library.
We call that color enchilada
red because of, you know, the --
right, the -- the likeness
to the red tortillas.
But anyway, and this is where
I first became both familiar
with the resources that library's
steward and also with the personnel,
the people that steward
those resources
and that really took an interest
in me and in my life, in my career
and my development at
a pretty early age.
So that was it, a little
bit about my experience.
I should say and I do want
to tell you a little bit
about my organization, The
Association of Research Libraries,
which is right here in
Washington D.C. It is not
like a -- a lot of associations.
The Association of Research
Libraries is an institutional
organization of 124 of the top,
well largest we would
say research libraries
in the United States and Canada.
So, a lot of your land
grant universities,
your big state schools, colleges and
universities are members of ours,
a lot of the Ivy League
schools are members.
And then we have a couple of
public libraries that are members,
the New York Public Library,
Boston Public Library
and we have quite a few federal
libraries, Library of Congress,
where you're visiting today, the
National Library of Medicine,
the National Archives, which
is just down the street.
I hope some of you might have
an opportunity to visit NARA.
Did I say the National
Library of Medicine?
That's the other one.
And I think those are
the -- the federals.
And excuse me, I'm --
I'm very warm today.
Sorry about that.
So, I was asked -- asked
to talk a little bit
about -- about the profession.
And we heard a little
bit already about why --
why libraries are still relevant
today and why should be --
they be in the age of fake news, in
the age of ubiquitous information
where you can literally get
on Google or get on your phone
and find information
almost anywhere.
Why is this profession
still important, right?
And that has already been
expressed a little bit.
But, what is the library?
What makes a library, right?
Most people when they
think of libraries,
they think of very
large repositories as --
as this esteemed institution
here, right.
We think of books.
We think of manuscripts,
right, papers, people's papers.
Before there was email, people would
write memos and actually send them
to people, audio recordings, videos.
I was actually a music librarian
when I was actually still
a practicing librarian.
That's what I did.
I have a Master's degree
in Vocal Performance.
And that's what I did for a little
while before coming over to the --
to the dark side of
association work.
We think about maps.
We think about periodicals, right.
Not too many newspapers
around anymore.
Most of those are in
digital format, but --
but nevertheless, libraries
traditionally collect all those
sorts of things, a lot of
the journals that you who are
in academic institutions,
you know, that --
that you gain access
to every single day.
So what is the library?
Well, things have changed a little
bit, right, or maybe quite a lot.
So libraries are still repositories,
right, places where there are lots
of collections of things, of these
physical things that you can touch,
that you can smell, that you can
read, that you can take out and take
to the -- take to the beach,
right, these sorts of things.
But they're also a lot of
different things these days, right.
And especially in my context which
is academic in research libraries.
It's a lot about digital content,
a lot about digital content.
It's about databases, right.
It's about these large databases
that index the resources
that you need for your research
papers and that sort of thing
so that you can go and
perform searches to figure
out what exactly are the best
resources for the research
that you're trying to do.
Electronic and digital resources --
that's the actual content, right,
the actual articles that you
seek out to do your research
or to find information or to
entertain yourself if that's,
you know, how you choose
to access that information.
A lot of what's happening
in libraries right now I
think is very exciting.
This is one of the most
exciting pieces of it is
about maker spaces, right.
And we're talking everything
from, you know,
from primary school age
children to very, very advanced,
like gaming technology that informs
things like, you know, like --
like these sophisticated war
modeling and things like that.
It's really a very
interesting and exciting thing.
If you have an opportunity, I -- I
encourage you to get online and look
for the North Carolina State
University, and look for -- There --
there are videos about
the Hunt Library.
It's a -- a side tech
campus in -- in --
in the research triangle
in North Carolina.
And they will -- they have some
of the most interesting things
that you'll ever see, huge walls
where they do data visualization.
They have gaming areas where
people work with gaming technology
and that sort of thing,
streaming audio and video,
like these large aggregators,
these people who collect all
of this content of -- of
speech, of sound, of, you know,
every variety of music and
art that you can imagine,
and make that content available
just, you know, on your phone
or on a laptop and data
-- data, data, data.
Data is huge these days, right.
I'm sure you all know that.
You can make a career out of just
how to manage and describe data.
And then thinking about libraries
as really extending much, much,
much beyond the walls, but
also how it exists in the --
in virtual reality, right,
and all these resources
that are interconnected
on a -- on a global scale,
especially with respect to
researchers and that sort of thing
in terms of sharing resources on
the cloud and that sort of thing.
So did I miss anything?
Did I miss anything?
Is the library anything
else to you other
than what I've articulated
here today
in just these few bullet points?
It's people?
Yeah, we'll get there.
Yeah, absolutely, yeah it
is people, right, exactly.
Anything else?
No? I've covered it all.
Okay, good, great, excellent, good.
So, let's go back to the
people, the people aspect of it.
So what is this, the thing that
we call a librarian, right?
People who go through formal
education today is largely called a
Library and Information Science.
There are many different
sectors as I mentioned earlier.
There are those in public
libraries like the one
that I showed the picture of in
the San Antonio Public Library,
are those who are employed
and engaged in school
as school librarians are
as media specialists.
There are academic libraries,
librarians that are focused largely
on college and university campuses.
And there are special libraries,
things like law libraries,
things like those who are focused
on health sciences are also science
and technology, these
sorts of things.
So these have been sort
of the largely traditional
categories I think
of those people of the personnel.
And things are again changing quite
a bit and have changed quite a bit.
So when we think about librarians
today, these are a lot of the --
This is a lot of the taxonomy, a
lot of the language that we used
to describe the role of
people: public services,
that traditional reference
librarian that you would go up to
at a desk even though those are kind
of disappearing a lot these days,
right, because of electronic means,
but the one that you would go up
and ask a reference question to;
access services, the type of person
that allows access, that will rent
-- that will check out, not rent,
but check out a book to
you and that sort of thing
or that will organize the
resources in the library;
instruction librarians --
it's very, very important --
instruction librarians who teach
people how to think critically
about those resources
that they're searching
for when they're doing
research, when they're trying
to find an answer to a
question, and many, many others.
Technical services is
about description, right.
It's about creating those taxonomies
and those terms that are going
to help you when you go
to a search engine to --
to uncover a resource
that you really need;
subject liaison librarians and
getting into the technical part
of it; those who deal with the back
end like the system's librarian
to deal with the -- the
computer infrastructure
to make a library work today.
But these days, and on -- on this
other side on the right side of --
of the slide, I have
highlighted some interesting roles
that are currently in much
demand, in high demand,
especially in a research
intensive environment --
in an academic environment.
Scholarly publishing or scholarly
communication's librarians that deal
with all that creative,
that research output,
all of those journals that are
being published at very, very,
very high cost to the consumer and
to students who are, you know --
You've -- you've had to pay
for a lot of these, right;
digital stewardship and digital
archivists, electronic resources.
These days in an academic library,
sometimes as much as 70 percent
of a library's budget can go toward
electronic resources as opposed
to monograph, as opposed to books,
which by the way sell often even
the traditional book preferred mode
of delivery is often in
the electronic form also.
Things like digital humanities,
looking across the humanities
disciplines and the engagement
of digital resources and textural
analysis and this sort of thing.
User experience and
assessment, looking at things
like computer human interaction
and that sort of thing; geographic
and information system, very,
very much in demand today,
and of course looking at pairing
this with the public services
and the instruction instructional
design, looking at those pedagogies
within an academic institution
that is going to optimize learning
for students that's going to
allow you to learn as much
as you possibly can and
position you to find the answers
to those research questions.
So those are some of the
kind of sexier, if you would,
sexier roles today, as opposed to
information science these days,
which I can go on a little bit.
We've talked a little bit about it.
But in terms of focus on knowledge
management in terms of just,
you know, taking the scope --
a survey of what knowledge is within
the purview is within your personnel
and that sort of thing; web
services: health informatics,
looking at health information
on a broad scale,
as well as small scales, looking
at [inaudible] information,
cyber infrastructure.
We talked about a lot of this, and
looking at information architecture.
In other words, all of the
things behind all of these tools
that you're using on a day to day
basis to find information and how is
that technology assisting that?
So, that's a bit about
the profession today.
There are lots of really interesting
and exciting things -- Oh thank you.
That's great.
I appreciate that -- going on in
the profession and I just wanted
to give you a little
glimpse about that.
But for the next few minutes, I just
wanted to talk about the other side
of what I do, which is why I
think largely I'm here today.
And that is talking about the
diversity of the profession
and inclusion in profession
-- in the profession.
A lot of times, what people
think about when they think
about diversity is thinking
about this, statistics --
statistics about representation,
okay.
How many women are in
the profession, right?
How many Latinics are
in the profession?
That sort of thing, right?
How many people who are veterans are
in your workforce and
that sort of thing?
Those things are terribly,
terribly important
and I think we do have
to think about those.
Librarianship is not real
different from many, many sectors.
It's about -- I mean when we
look overall in terms of sectors,
it's kind of right in the middle,
not quite as good as -- as --
as the military, not quite
as good maybe as education,
but a bit better than other sectors.
And I apologize that
the -- that the --
the slide here is a little
bit strange in its display.
But this is where we are, our
small group of 124 libraries.
Actually, this represents 99 of
them in colleges and universities
in the US because we don't
track those data in --
for our Canadian institutions.
But right now are as
effective at 214, 2015,
we had about almost 15 percent
representation of racial
and ethnic minorities if you would,
people from historically
underrepresented groups.
And that's only representing
those --
those categories that
are listed there.
This is where we were in 1998.
So we were at about 11.2 percent.
So we haven't grown a heck
of a lot in spite of a lot
of scholarship opportunities and
pipeline programs such as the ones
that you are participating in.
This is where we are
profession-wide, profession-wide
within library information science,
we earn about 12 percent
representation of racial
and ethnic minorities, okay.
So we clearly have a long
way to go if we're going
to represent the populations
that we serve.
This is what gender looks like
in our university libraries.
So we're at about 36.4 percent male.
This is actually -- these
data a little bit older.
The library -- librarianship
in general is
about actually depending
on what source.
You consult about 82
to 86 percent women.
And then age diversity.
It's actually very, very diverse.
We're at a stage right now
where we basically have
about five generations in
the professional workforce
at this particular time,
which creates all kinds
of interesting challenges I
think and -- and opportunities.
And then this is where we are or
this is where we are projected
that we will be in the United
States by 2050 that we will be
at about 50 percent
representation of -- of those --
those four categories again.
So we have a long way to go.
And this is where higher education
is also moving very, very quickly,
becoming much more
diverse very, very quickly.
So, how are we doing on time?
Okay. I just want to
maybe touch just very,
very quickly on two
-- two other points.
What I see going on in the
work that I do I think has --
is -- is very, very critical.
We are at a critical juncture
here within our profession,
within our society
within the United States.
There has been sort of a -- a
transfer, a thinking if you will,
a thinking about the state of
diversity which is really only
about a state of being, right, and
thinking about the work that we do
as centering on inclusion, that is
creating environments where people
like you and like me feel welcome,
like we don't have to fake it to fit
in in these environments
that we -- that --
in which we work, right
and with our colleagues.
I think that, you know, like the
business sector has been talking
about inclusion for the better part
of probably 25 or 30 years or so.
I like this, you know,
this definition.
Diversity is just the mix of
all of those human identities
and inclusion is really
making the mix work.
But this is what I see and
you can't see the bottom.
I'm sorry about that.
I'll -- I'll explain to -- This is
where I think we are headed today.
This natural progression from
thinking about diversity,
taking it a step further,
thinking about inclusion
and then even towards equity,
focusing on social justice
and that last little point that
you can't see is de-colonization.
I think we are at a stage where
although I think if programs
like this internship
program that you're involved
with like the scholarship programs
that I manage are terribly,
terribly important, right.
When we think about
diversifying our workforce, right,
where do we have opportunities
to really affect change?
We're not going to change
the demographics of the --
of my age group, the
40 to 60 year olds.
We're not going to
affect change there.
We are going to affect --
affect change at your level,
at people who are just now entering
whatever professional environment
that you're preparing
yourself to enter, right.
Now the idea of colonization I think
is an important one and it's one
that we really have
to think critically
about because it really focuses us
-- forces us to focus on systems,
on those historical barriers
to inequality and to inequity.
Those things that throughout are
-- are throughout our history,
especially a lot of it here
in the US has really created
those systemic barriers
to true inclusion being created.
So, I could say a lot
more about that.
We'll maybe hopefully we'll
-- we'll save time for that.
Just last few comments.
Thinking about leadership and
thinking about management,
and I want to differentiate
those for you.
It's important I think for many of
you to develop managerial skills
that is budgetary management,
like project management skills,
these sorts of things, personnel
management skills to better yourself
and to allow yourself to
advance in your profession.
But I want to close thinking
about and give you a challenge
to be thinking about
leadership and how
that is different than management.
I love these guys,
Kouzes and Posner.
They're very, very big in
the research literature,
and this is how they
define leadership:
the art of mobilizing others to want
to struggle for shared aspirations.
I'm going to go into this just
a little bit more as I close.
I want you think about
-- This also based on --
on that Kouzes and Posner's model --
about leadership being
everybody's business.
So it's not about positional
authority.
You do not have to be Karla
Hayden to be a leader.
You do not have to be the CEO of
a company to be a leader, right.
Leadership can and should happen
at any layer of an organization.
Leadership is also about
building relationships.
It's about building relationships
with the people that you would
like to lead that are
willing to embrace your vision
of where you would
like to take them.
It's also about self-development.
It's about creating what we say the
leadership -- the leadership says --
literature says authority
and credibility.
So, I challenge you to -- to --
to think about creating a path
to becoming the best
practitioner you can possibly be
because that lends
to that credibility.
The best leaders are the
best -- the best learners.
They're always on the path
to improving themselves,
to improving their practice,
and it -- and it is deliberate.
You really have to think about it.
It's also intentional.
A last few things --
last few things.
I would hope that in
whatever you decide to --
to pursue professionally and --
and outside of your profession that
the things that you take leadership
in align with your values,
with your belief structure.
That is really critical and
that is going to feed you
as develop yourself as leaders.
Leadership requires modeling.
It means that you not only have
to tell people how to act and what
to do, but you have to
constantly model that behavior
for the people who
want to follow you.
And it requires vision.
It requires a vision that can be
articulated, that can be shared
and that can -- that
other people can buy into.
We talked about credibility,
oh goodness, sorry.
And then -- and finally
leadership is about building trust.
It's about building trust so that
people will want to follow you
and that will want to
fully embrace that vision.
So, I'll end up with a
little bit of Dr. Seuss.
This is why I think people
from underrepresented groups,
people from your age bracket if
I can be a little ageist here,
have to think about leadership.
People are often frustrated
with leadership, right -- right?
People complain about their
bosses if we're talking
about managerial leadership.
They -- they complain
about their bosses a lot.
And if you don't take the time to
care an awful lot about the work
that you're doing and about the
organization that employs you
and if you don't build within
yourself the desire to be a leader,
then you're leaving leadership
up to some other people
who maybe don't have the
skills or don't have the vision
or don't have the passion to --
to at least enough to what
you to -- to follow them.
So think about this a little bit,
and we can open this
up for discussion.
Those are my comments.
[ Applause ]
Questions, comments.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Yeah, sure.
Okay, so actually, it's systemic.
We want to think about systemic.
This is the example that I
give, particularly in academe,
as I think about the --
the promotion and tenure
system in a traditional --
How many of you want
to be academics?
You want to be professors?
Anybody here want to be professors?
No? You? Yes, you want
to be a professor?
Okay. So, thinking about the world
experience and thinking about things
like that are really,
really critical
to people achieving tenure
in a university, right.
So permanent status,
continuing status has a lot to do
with mentorship and it has a lot do
with being -- being
exposed to things.
People from historically
underrepresented groups frequently
do not have that -- that experience.
They do not have that world view.
They do not have people and mentors.
It's very, very, very difficult for
them to find people to engage with
and to have conversations with to
talk about the struggles of what
that promotion and
tenure process is like.
So that systemic thing is that
the system was really built --
If we think about how
universities were built many, many,
many moons ago, it was
really built to ensure
that the literate classes
stayed in power, right.
That's -- that's really
-- It really wasn't
about dissemination
at the time, okay.
So that means that there is this
historical legacy that -- that --
that really is built around higher
education that makes it very,
very difficult for people of color
to achieve -- to achieve tenure.
So that's just kind of an example.
I mean I can give you, you
know, lots of other examples
that are based on economics,
right, that are based
on any number of different factors.
That's -- that's an
excellent question.
Other questions or comments?
Reflections?
Yes.
[ Inaudible Question ]
Into librarianship itself?
Yeah.
>> Can you repeat the question?
>> Mark Puente: Sure.
What can be done to recruit
or to encourage more minorities
to enter librarianship?
I would -- I would say that
-- Can I expand that question?
And let's talk about any field.
So, I think that -- Let me give you
an example in -- in librarianship.
You know, we've had these
programs, these scholarships,
these pipeline programs that
have been very, very beneficial
that have offered lots of money.
I -- I was a product
of one of those.
I'm a graduate of the
University of Arizona program.
They have a program called
The Knowledge River Program,
which focuses specifically
on Latinics and made
of American populations to try to
recruit them into librarianship.
So, I got that second Masters with
no student loan debt, which is a --
a social justice issue
by the way, right --
right, social justice because of
the finances involved with that.
So, but -- but here's the thing.
The recruitment addresses
the numbers,
but it doesn't address retention.
The 12 percent that I talked about
of representation across racial
and ethnic minorities within
the profession has been static
for about 20 -- about 20 years
in spite of a lot of programs.
So we are only able -- being
able to recruit as many people
from historically underrepresented
groups, as there is attrition, okay.
Now, a lot of them -- There could
be lots of reasons for attrition,
but we know from research that one
of the reasons there is attrition is
because people are going to
higher paying sectors, right,
but also because frequently
they are encountering barriers,
barriers to promotion, to
continuance, that sort of thing.
And they're finding in
many -- in many instances,
they're finding the
institutions and the organizations
where they are employed and engaged
to be less than inclusive, right,
where they don't feel welcomed,
where they do feel like they
in order to be successful, they
have to really kind of fake it.
They have to, you know, play
the game and act like, you know,
they're from majority
cultures, and that's very,
very difficult and
very disheartening.
And that is why some people leave.
So, I think it's a very --
that's a very long answer to say
that if we can focus on culture
and building cultures of inclusion
and also to think about what --
what interventions are necessary,
you know, what do we as
leaders, people, you know,
who are in positional authority,
what do they have to do to instill
within their organization
an authentic commitment
to create an inclusive environment?
That is a very, very difficult
conversation, but luckily,
you know from my vantage point
with the ARL, which our --
our member representatives
are all the --
the CEOs, they're all the deans,
the directors, the university --
the head librarians of these
large organizations, those are --
those are conversations that
they are much more willing
to have these days.
And so I'm very excited
about the future of that.
But I -- I do think that --
that is very much a part of it.
Comments, yes?
Questions, yes?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Library of Congress?
>> I didn't hear the question.
>> Mark Puente: Can
you -- can you --
>> Repeat the question.
[ Inaudible Question ]
>> Mark Puente: Yeah.
How do you show leadership --
>> Yeah.
>> Mark Puente: -- rather
than management when working
with employees and interns?
>> Correct.
>> Mark Puente: That's
-- that's your question.
[ Inaudible Statement ]
Sure. I think that -- that
-- I mean, there are --
there are built-in
if I'm not mistaken,
opportunities for example
to cultivate leadership
development within LC.
Historically, they still exist.
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
And we -- and we do that as
well at the ARL, the Association
of Research Libraries that --
We have several leadership
development programs
where we build these cohorts.
We take people out of their work
-- everyday workplace context,
although I think LC focused
specifically on this institution
and -- and allows people to --
to take time out of their days
to develop these interests
and to understand first of
all what are the philosophies,
what are the theories behind
developing yourself as the leader
and then secondly, what do you do?
You know, providing practical real
world opportunities for applications
of those skills within
the workforce.
So, I think one of the things
that -- that -- that myself --
I mean what I have found
with working with students
that are largely graduate students
is that -- I mean they are eager.
They are really eager to
lead conversations, projects,
initiatives, whatever that sort of
thing is, and what we need to do
as leaders is simply
give them the agency
to -- to -- to let them do it.
I mean leadership is about --
I think true leadership is
about cultivating the talent
within your constituency
whatever that is,
and then letting them do it,
right, just letting them go.
And sometimes that means
allowing them to fail, right.
But hopefully you have the --
the infrastructure and the
mentoring capacity behind that to --
to kind of offset some of that.
You know, hopefully
that -- that exists.
But I think that --
that's largely --
Most of it is allowing
that person or those people
to develop those interests,
to develop those skills
and then giving them a really --
an opportunity to practically engage
those skills and see where it goes.
Thank you.
That was a rough question.
Any other comments or questions?
Well, I think we'll
wrap things up then.
So thank you.
>> Eric Eldritch: Stay here.
>> Mark Puente: Oh, yes I will
stay here, yes, absolutely.
>> Eric Eldritch: So in --
in closing, I want to ask --
Can you just tell me some
of the majors that you're --
that you're coming
from over in this area?
What majors are you from?
Social work?
Sociology?
>> Business.
>> Eric Eldritch: Business.
>> Public health.
>> Eric Eldritch: Public health.
>> Communications.
>> Eric Eldritch: Communications.
>> Marketing.
>> Eric Eldritch: Marketing.
Regulatory Science.
So there are libraries for
all of those endeavors.
>> Mark Puente: Absolutely.
Yeah, yes there are, yeah.
>> Eric Eldritch: How many
of you know the libraries
that specialize in
your career's field?
So if you were into agriculture,
there's the National
Agricultural Library.
>> Mark Puente: Right.
>> Eric Eldritch: But it's
also important for you to --
to understand that you
have a home library.
So how many of you still have a
library card from your home area?
Maybe. One of the things
that I've noticed is
that information is
becoming expensive.
And it's really important
for us to look at this.
If you've looked a local
newspaper, you found that there --
they want to charge
you a subscription fee.
You get three articles a month
that you get -- that you get.
After that, you need to pay
for those kinds of things.
Having a membership in your
local library, maintaining a link
with your school library, allows
you to have other open doors,
and I think that that's the part
of librarianship that is going
to lead you and your
generation to be able to figure
out other smarter ways to
continue to have access.
Any other --
>> Mark Puente: Right.
>> Eric Eldritch: --
closing remarks about access
to information in their time?
>> Mark Puente: Yeah.
I mean, I just -- I mean, just
to reiterate what you said,
I think we're in a -- in
an environment where --
where information -- I mean it's
so ubiquitous and it's really,
really difficult to -- to --
to manage that and to figure
out what is most relevant to us
because this is going to
help us inform, you know,
who we are as citizens, you know
and -- and things like, you know,
where we -- we donate and who
we vote for and, you know,
what schools we support and
what school policies we support
and that sort of thing.
So, I think it's really, really
critical to -- to think about how --
how that filter is
developed within you.
I mean, it's -- it's
probably more important
than ever I think, so, yeah.
But -- And also to say that if
anybody is interested or would
like more information about
scholarship opportunities, I --
I could certainly have conversations
with you and can point you
to resources about plenty
of scholarship opportunities
for library and Information Science.
So, happy to do that as well.
>> Eric Eldritch: Again, thank you
very much for being here today.
>> Mark Puente: Sure thing.
Thank you, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Eric Eldritch: And we do want
to thank you for coming here today.
We hope that your experience at the
Library of Congress is something
that will whet your appetite,
that you will come back,
bring your friends,
bring your families.
We have weekend tours, but there's
so much available at
your fingertips.
So do visit us onsite and online.
Thank you very much for coming
to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]